und wir schauen schon mal auf den
nächsten Tagesordnungspunkt es geht um
einen Antrag der Fraktionen der cdu/csu
und zwar nämlich wie mit dem Wolf
umgegangen wird und wie eben dort er
geschützt wird aber natürlich auch der
Mensch und sein Hab und Gut geschützt
werden kann die Unionsfraktion erfordert
dass sich Deutschland da an EU-Staaten
wie Schweden Finnland oder Frankreich
orientiert und zum Beispiel auch das
Bundesjagdgesetz ändert das würde
bedeuten dass nämlich der Wolf in den
Katalog der jagdbaren Arten aufgenommen
wird momentan ist er ja noch streng
geschützt und das ist dann in der
Debatte mitunter schwierig genaueres
wird uns Klaus im Mark dazu sagen er ist
einerseits Mitglied der Unionsfraktion
aber war auch 2006 bis 2021
Bürgermeister in der Stadt Bad Wildbach
und Bad Wildbach unter anderem 2018
Schlagzeilen als dort einen Wolf
tatsächlich 32 Schafe gerissen hat
ja frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren ein Bürgermeister aus
Sachsen berichtet von einem Wolfsrudel
das tagsüber durchs doch schlecht Kinder
gehen dort aus Angst nicht mehr zu Fuß
zur Schule vorletzte Woche haben Wölfe
eine ganze Alpakaherde ausgelöscht die
Zäune wurden untergraben inzwischen
müssen in Niedersachsen in Brandenburg
selbst grüne und rote Umweltministerin
Abschuss von Wölfen erleichtern meine
Damen und Herren ich habe die zuständige
Staatssekretärin mit diesen Fragen hier
im Plenum konfrontiert sie meinte dass
Märchen von Rotkäppchen und dem bösen
Wolf sei außer zählt das Märchen ist
aber nicht außer zählt ganz im Gegenteil
wir schlagen gerade ein neues Kapitel
auf und wenn wir jetzt nicht handeln
dann wird es auch kein Happy End geben
meine Damen und Herren
seit dem Jahr 2000 breitet sich der Wolf
exponentiell aus die Bestände wachsen
jährlich um rund 30 Prozent in
Deutschland gibt es mehr als 2012
rechnen Sie das mal auf die nächsten
zehn Jahre hoch dabei ist jetzt schon
klar dass wir beim Wolf von einem
günstigen Erhaltungszustand ausgehen
können und natürlich ist das einer Volk
für den Artenschutz es geht ja auch
nicht darum den Wolf wieder auszurotten
es geht darum den Bestand zu regeln so
wie bei jeder anderen Wildtierart auch
sonst werden wir die Folgen nicht in den
Griff bekommen erkennen sie endlich an
dass der Wolf in manchen Gegenden
Deutschlands schon jetzt zum echten
Problem geworden ist meine Damen und
Herren
wir haben zunehmend Schäden durch
Angriffe auf Weide und Haustiere 2020
wurden allein rund 4.000 Weidetiere
getötet jetzt hat es sogar das Pony
unserer kommissionspräsidentin erwischt
aber das ist ja nur die prominente
Spitze eines Eisberges es geht um die
vielen weidetierhalter
Präventionsmaßnahmen sind eben nicht
immer wirksam schwere wolfszäune lassen
sich eben nicht immer die steilen Hänge
hinauftragen die weidetierhaltung ist
vielerorts ernsthaft bedroht aber so
weit darf es nicht kommen mit ihren grün
roten Träumereien und einer völlig
falschen Romantisierung des Wolfes
setzen Sie den Erhalt unserer
Kulturlandschaft auf Spiel meine Damen
und Herren
wissen Sie ich war als Bürgermeister
derjenige der im Schwarzwald erstmals
erleben müsste wenn ein Wolf in einer
Nacht im Blutrausch 20 Schafe tötet und
die von hinten angefressenen Körper
morgens noch lebend auf der Weide liegen
offensichtlich wird wir hier wieder
einmal von Berliner Schreibtischen aus
über Probleme sinniert ohne mit den
Menschen vor Ort zu sprechen das ist
ungefähr so wie wenn zwei Wölfe und ein
Schaf darüber abstimmen was es zum
Abendessen gibt meine Damen und Herren
den Menschen den Menschen vor Ort im
ländlichen Raum hilft das aber nichts es
wird hier nur an den Folgen
herumgedocktert das
Bundesumweltministerium weigert sich das
Problem grundlegend anzugehen wir
fordern ein aktives
wolfsbestandsmanagement setzen Sie sich
bei der EU-Kommission dafür ein dass der
Wolf von Anhang 4 in Anhang 5 der
FFH-Richtlinie eingestuft wird lassen
sie uns des Bundesjagdgesetz ändern und
legen Sie wolfsfreie Gebiete fest denn
wo stehen wir heute die Grünen würden am
liebsten mit dem Wolf tanzen und alles
laufen lassen hätte es die SPD bei den
Gebrüdern Grimm schon gegeben wurde
Rotkäppchen wahrscheinlich hinter einem
Schutzzaun sitzen wollen sie am Ende den
ganz Deutschland einzäunen einzig die
FDP weiß eigentlich was zu tun wäre sie
haben einen entsprechenden Antrag 2018
schon gestellt sie müssen aber natürlich
heute wieder gegen ihre eigene
überzeugungsstimmen dazu sage ich nur
liebe Kollegen von der FDP wer sich
selbst nicht so scharf macht den fressen
am Ende die Wölfe haben Sie den Mut
haben Sie den Mut unseren Antrag zu
unterstützen im Sinne unserer
Landschaftspfleger im Sinne der Menschen
vor Ort helfen Sie mit unsere schöne
Kulturlandschaft in Deutschland zu
erhalten ich danke Ihnen
die meisten Wölfe die in Deutschland
bekannt sind Leben in Brandenburg
Niedersachsen und Sachsen und der
nächste Redner kommt auch aus in
Niedersachsen a pardon noch nicht Lina
Seidel spricht zuerst für die
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen sehr verehrte Damen
und Herren ich möchte mal mit guten
Nachrichten beginnen wir haben jetzt
hier alle viel Spaß gehabt ich möchte
mal mit einer Erfolgsgeschichte anfangen
der Wolf war in den fast 150 Jahren in
Deutschland ausgerottet heute wächst die
Population wieder und das ist eine gute
Nachricht angesichts der Tatsache dass
fast 7000 Tierarten hierzulande vom
Aussterben bedroht ist der Rück die
Rückkehr des Wolfes zeigt das
europäische nationale Schutzmaßnahmen
der Wolf
sorgt natürlich aber auch gerade für
viel Aufregungen in einigen Regionen
Deutschlands verursachen wolfsrisse
Schäden und sie beunruhigen anwohnende
was aber sie Liebe unionsfraktionen in
ihrem Antrag fordern das steht in keinem
Verhältnis zu dem was sie eigentlich
fordern wollen was auch in ihrem Titel
drinsteht nämlich eine ausgewogene
Balance ich zitiere zwischen dem Schutz
von Mensch und Tier sowie dem
Artenschutz gut gemeint ist eben nicht
gut gemacht wenn es nach ihnen ginge
sollten wir sogenannte wolfsfreie Zonen
schaffen die Entnahme einer
spezifizierten Anzahl von Wölfen
erlauben ein fairer Kompromiss zwischen
dem Schutz des Tieres und den Interessen
der Landwirtschaft ist es ein nicht es
ist ein Abschuss ohne Wenn und Aber was
sie hier fordern sonst nichts
und ich erinnere Sie gerne daran dass
wir hier in dem Haus gemeinsam spd-union
2019 des Bundesnaturschutzgesetz
geändert haben und wir genau das
hergestellt haben was sie jetzt
behaupten zu tun nämlich eine
ausgewogene Balance wir haben damals
sachlich und mit Verstand verhandelt den
Abschluss von Wölfen haben wir
erleichtert wenn die Tiere ernste
landwirtschaftliche Schäden verursachen
und wir haben zum ersten Mal sowohl
Schäden in der Landwirtschaft als auch
Schäden bei hobbitierhalterinnen und
hobbytierhalter berücksichtigt
nach geltendem Recht kann bereits jetzt
im schlimmsten Fall ein ganzes
Wolfsrudel entnommen werden bis Schäden
ausbleihen wie Sie sehen wir legen viel
Wert auf die Sorgen der Landwirtschaft
wir machen aber auch solide Politik die
den EU-Richtlinien entspricht
die Gesetzesnovelle die wir gemeinsam
mit ihnen verabschiedet haben die gilt
selbstverständlich auch den Menschen der
Abschluss von Wölfen ist demnach möglich
wenn ein Wolf ein Menschen verletzt ihn
verfolgt oder sich ihm gegenüber
unprovoziert aggressiv zeigt mit diesen
Änderungen haben wir Sicherung
Sicherheit für alle geschaffen für die
Tiere für den Wolf und für den Menschen
wir haben diese Novelle 2019
verabschiedet jetzt muss sie evaluiert
werden wie die Umsetzung vor Ort
funktioniert zusammen mit den Ländern
der Landwirtschaft den Naturschutz der
Bevölkerung eine Novelle nach der
anderen vorzuschlagen ist dagegen
unnötige Aktionismus und keine seriöse
Politik sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
im Antrag erfordern sie und jetzt gehe
ich noch mal genauer auf ihren Antrag
einem Antrag fordern sie dass der
Erhaltungszustand des Wolfes in
Deutschland unverzüglich zu definieren
und jährlich zu bewerten sein ich möchte
gerne daran erinnern dass Deutschland zu
den Ländern mit den detailliertesten und
umfassenden
monitoringsstandards gehört nirgendwo in
Europa werden wolfspopulationen so
sorgfältig gezählt und überwacht
jährlich diese Daten werden jährlich von
den Ländern gesammelt in einem
aufwendigen Verfahren wissenschaftlich
ausgewertet es gibt hier keine
Geheimnisse und keine Unklarheiten
so wurden in Deutschland für das
Monitoring Jahr 2020
158 Rudels 27 wolfspaare 19 sesshafte
einzelwölfe und damit insgesamt 43
adulte Würfel gezählt zu keiner anderen
Art gibt es in Deutschland so viele
detaillierte Daten wie zum Wolf das ist
die Wahrheit
und sie schreiben weiter man sollte die
Kriterien für den Erhaltungszustand des
Wolfes offenlegen liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen das hat mich etwas verwundert
denn diese Informationen sind ebenfalls
alle öffentlich zugänglich es geht um
die Gesamtzahl der Population aber das
ist nicht das einzige Kriterium es geht
auch um die Verbreitung es geht um die
Größe und Qualität des Habitats und es
geht um die Zukunftsausrichtung Aussicht
aussichtung von für die Entwicklung des
Wolfes es geht also um eine insgesamte
Verteilung und die um die genetische
Vielfalt der Population bei der
Bewertung wie es gut ist dem Wolf in
Deutschland geht
und es geht also mein soliden
wissenschaftlichen
schutzansatz und nicht um Schlagzeilen
und auch wenn sich der deutsche
Wolfsbestand und ich glaube da sind wir
uns einig in den vergangenen Jahren
positiv entwickelt hat ist es Gesamtbild
dieser Kriterien immer noch nicht genug
um Wölfe einfach so abschießen zu können
auch wenn das hier von Ihnen gewünscht
wird sehr geehrte Damen und Herren nach
150 Jahren ohne Wolf kehrt dieses Tier
nun wieder in unsere Wälder zurück und
schließt damit eine Lücke in unserem
Ökosystem das ist eine gute Nachricht
und ich wünschte mir wir könnten solche
Erfolge für den Artenschutz jede
Sitzungswoche hier verkünden
diese Rückkehr bringt aber
selbstverständlich Herausforderung für
alle Mensch und Tier deshalb brauchen
wir ein gutes Monitoringsystem Maßnahmen
zum Herrn Schutz eine finanzielle
Kompensation für beide Tierhalter eine
regelmäßige Überprüfung der aktuellen
Situation und ja auch in Einzelfällen
die Entnahme von Einzeltieren im Rahmen
der Möglichkeiten des
Bundesnaturschutzgesetzes und der
europäischen Regelung was wir definitiv
nicht brauchen sind populistische
Forderungen vielen Dank
sagt Lena Salz für die SPD-Fraktion und
ich hatte ja eben schon Frank Ring
angefangen anzukündigen weil er aus
Niedersachsen kommt und wo eben auch
Wölfe leben und weil er auch
ausgebildeter Landwirt ist hier spricht
der als Mitglied der afd-fraktion
frau Präsidentin Werte Kollegen heute
unterhalten wir uns zum zweiten Mal in
diesem Jahr über das leidige und einfach
zu lösende wolfsprobleme in Deutschland
die Wölfe erobern mittlerweile nicht nur
unsere ländlichen Räume sondern auch
unsere Städte wie beispielsweise die
niedersächsische Landeshauptstadt
Hannover und ihre Region auch ehemalige
Verteidigungsministerin können sich
mittlerweile zu den Betroffenen Haltern
von getöteten Tieren zählen scheinbar
ist das in Verbindung mit der
niedersächsischen Landtagswahl nun
endlich grund genug dass auch die CDU
sich damit beschäftigt liebe Kollegen
von der CDU
liebe Kollegen von der CDU ich frage
mich warum sie vor wenigen Monaten
unseren Antrag abgelehnt haben und nun
weite Teile unsere Begründung und
unseres Antrags in ihrem übernommen
haben
lesen Sie mal ihre Begründung ab dem
dritten Satz haben sie abgeschrieben und
das kann man auch sehen ich habe da auch
sehr darüber gestaunt das mal zum einen
nun ist es ja nicht so dass nur sie
versprochen haben die Voice Probleme zu
regulieren auch die FDP hat das vor der
Bundestagswahl getan und meine Damen und
Herren heute Nachmittag saßen wir im
Ausschuss Saal des
landwirtschaftsunternährungsausschusses
und haben dort die Brüsseler Erklärung
entgegengenommen von einigen
weidetierhaltern und zu meinem Erstaunen
habe ich festgestellt dass auch die SPD
und die Linke unbedingt die
Wolfsbestände regulieren wollen darum
kann ich ja nur sagen heute werden wir
sicherlich alle ihrem Antrag zustimmen
und das wolfsproblem ein für alle Mal
lösen
mittlerweile wissen wir dass es keine
wolfssicheren Zäune gibt wie uns Grünen
wolfsfreundlichen Ideologen Vereine und
Verbände weismachen wollten genauso
wenig bewährt haben sich die
Herdenschutzhunde die im Grunde nicht
weniger gefährlich sind als die Wölfe
außerdem gefährdet natürlich stimmt das
außerdem gefährdet der Wolf den
Hochwasserschutz und den Tourismus
beispielsweise bei mir zu Hause in der
Lüneburger Heide die Zahl der von Wölfen
getöteten Nutztiere hat sich trotz aller
herdenschutzmaßnahmen innerhalb von nur
zwei Jahren fast verdoppelt meine Damen
und Herren 4000 wolfsrisse in den
letzten im letzten Jahr lässt die
Dimension dieser Tierquälerei deutlich
werden und wenn ich wenn ich sowas höre
wie Erhalt von atemvielfalt in meiner
Nachbarin in meinem Nachbarlandkreis in
der Göhrde hat der Wolf das Muffelwild
ausgerottet soviel dann zu dem
atemerhalt
trotzdem wurde bisher nicht reagiert um
die Schäden zu reduzieren und die
aktuelle steuermittelverschwendung für
herdenschutzpräventionsmaßnahmen von
ungefähr 10 Millionen Euro im Jahr nicht
noch weiter auspuffern zu lassen ist die
Entnahme der Wölfe unbedingt notwendig
Wölfe haben keine natürlichen Feinde
nach wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen
würde eine Anzahl von ungefähr 1000
Tieren absolut ausreichen mehr als das
Doppelte an Wölfen schätzen auch die
geringsten Statistiken die es in unserem
Land gibt ich kann nur an ihren gesunden
Menschenverstand appellieren folgen wir
unseren schwedischen finnischen und
französischen Nachbarn und bejagen wir
die Wölfe um unsere weidetierhalter und
unsere Bevölkerung zu schützen vielen
Dank
Frank Rink war das für die afd-fraktion
nächster Redner ist Harald Ebner von
Bündnis 90 die Grünen erste Vorsitzende
des Ausschusses für Umwelt Naturschutz
und Lehrer Sicherheit und
Verbraucherschutz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir stecken in
der größten im größten Artensterben seit
Menschen gedenken die Wissenschaft warnt
vor einem Point of no Return und die
Union will Wölfe abschießen und um das
zu kaschieren was sie da in Wahrheit
wollen nämlich den Wolf wieder
auszurotten reden sie im Titel ihres
Antrags reden sie im Titel ihres Antrags
nicht nur von einer Balance sondern von
einer
ausgewogenen hören Sie doch mal zu
sondern von einer ausgewogenen Balance
also ich weiß ich habe jetzt lange mal
nachgedacht ich bin nicht drauf gekommen
was eine nicht ausgewogene Balance wäre
also da wäre vielleicht eine Beratung
durch das Institut für deutsche Sprache
gar nicht schlecht gewesen aber nicht
mal nicht mal die Überschrift Ihres
Antrags ergibt sinnle Liebe Union
genauso wenig der Inhalt hier geht der
blanke Populismus mit Ihnen durch wer in
ihrem Text nach Hilfen für den
Herdenschutz sucht der sucht sich einen
Wolf aber genau die brauchen wir doch
für die Walde Tierhaltung und die werden
wir auch auf den Weg bringen stattdessen
schüren sie Ängste Kollege Mack mit
Rotkäppchen sie Tischen Scheinlösungen
auf und
[Musik]
liefern keine konstruktiven Beiträge
unser wissenschaftlich vorbildliches
bestandsmonitoring das passt ihnen nicht
weil sie lieber mit aufgeblähten
Bestandszahlen Panik verbreiten wollen
sie fordern sie fordern was Gutes sie
fordern die Erfassung von von
riss-schäden und Kosten für den
Herdenschutz wunderbar das ist schön
aber das gibt es doch schon das gibt es
doch schon also vielleicht sollen sie
sich einfach mal die Berichte durchlesen
also das ist ja schön da müssen sie mit
ihren Anträgen früher aufstehen und ihr
ewiges Mantra der Wolf ins Jagdrecht das
wird durch ständige Wiederholung nicht
praktikabler sondern das erschwert durch
durch Kompetenz wirr war schnelle
Entnahmen und unsere Jäger die haben
doch wahrhaft besseres zu tun als von
ihnen noch den Abschuss von Wölfen
übergeholfen zu bekommen ich bin froh
wenn sie die Wildbestände so regulieren
können dass unser Wald vernünftig
aufwachsen kann
sie berufen sich mit ihren wolfsfreien
Zonen und bestandsregulierungen auf
Schweden was passiert denn in Schweden
die klein gehaltene Population ist durch
Inzucht gefährdet und genau deshalb sage
ich was sie da wollen ist eine
Ausrottung weil eine durch Inzucht
gefährdete Population ist oft dauert
nicht lebensfähig und außerdem hilft es
auch nicht sie kriegen doch die
ziehenden Jungwölfe gar nicht aus der
Welt und das was sie versprechen
funktioniert deshalb nur wenn sie den
Wolf flächendeckend wieder ausrotten und
es war Artenschutz in ihrem Antrag des
schämt sich ja fast schon selber und ja
ich wünsche mir von ihnen tatsächlich
mal eine konstruktive Oppositionsarbeit
statt einem Balanceakt wie es ihn
eigentlich Versprechen in ihrer
Überschrift haben sie leider schon
wieder das Gleichgewicht verloren danke
schön
Harald Ebner war das krieg hier noch
einige Mitteilungen mit auf dem Weg
allerdings eher auf der Rednerliste
steht nun Ina lattendorf von der
Linksfraktion
[Applaus]
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin verehrte Kollegen und
Kollegen der Wolf hat Deutschland ist in
Deutschland wieder zurück hat in die
Natur gefunden aber es läuft nicht alles
glatt der Antrags in der Unionsfraktion
trägt in Teilen den agrarpolitischen
Problematiken durchaus Rechnung das
Problem ist sie greifen in ihren
Schlussfolgerungen aber meiner Meinung
nach bisher fehlenden aber notwendigen
Daten vor wir haben leider faktisch
keine verlässlichen bundesweiten Daten
auch wenn wir hier gerade was anderes
gehört haben und Sie haben recht wenn
sie ein Monitoring und ein aktives
Bestandsmanagement fordern und dem
stimmen wir linken zu
denn ob man in Deutschland von einem
günstigen Erhaltungszustand des Wolfes
ausgehen kann wie sie allerdings
unterstellen ist umstritten das
Bundesministerium
Bundesumweltministerium zum Beispiel
sieht Wolfsbestände noch weit entfernt
von einem günstigen Erhaltungszustand
die deutschen Schafhalter auch heute
hier im Saal sehen diesen Zustand
natürlich als erreicht an angesichts der
risszahlen die Sie zu verzeichnen haben
und das Problem ist dass bislang jedes
Bundesland für sich das Wolfsmonitoring
eigenständig betreibt in meinem
Bundesland Mecklenburg-Vorpommern gehen
die Fachleute stand 21 von 14
Wolfsrudeln aus ist das zu viel was ist
der Maßstab klare und aktuelle Aussagen
zum Erhaltungszustand insgesamt
bundesweit fehlen und da ist definitiv
nachzubessern
liebe Kollegen aus der Union wenn Sie
nun fordern das Bundesjagdgesetz zu
ändern und den Wolf in den Katalog der
jagdbaren Arten aufzunehmen ist das
populistisch als wenn es so einfach wäre
in ihre Forderung den Wolf vom Anhang 4
in Anhang fünf der FFH-Richtlinie neu
einzustehen einzustufen sehe ich eine
ziemlich schräge Gleichstellung mit
Baummarder und Iltis und das wie gesagt
ohne belastbare Datengrundlage mit ihren
Forderungen tun sie den zweiten Schritt
vor den ersten lassen Sie uns den ersten
tun denn es geht auch darum zwischen
Naturerhaltung Nachhaltigkeit und
Wirtschaftlichkeit eine ausgewogene
Balance herzustellen das ist ja auch in
ihrem Wortlaut aber dazu reicht es nicht
einfach Wölfe abschießen zu lassen und
dann die weidetierhalter trotzdem im
Regen stehen zu lassen denn wenn Sie
etwas für die Weidehaltung tun wollen
dann folgen Sie unsere jahrelangen
Forderung helfen Sie mit einen
verlässlichen bundesweit einheitlichen
Rechtsanspruch auf Erstattung aller
Aufwendungen für den Herdenschutz
inklusive der abgel der verbundenen
Arbeitszeit zu garantieren zweitens
realisieren sie dass die soziale
Absicherung der weidetierhalter jeder
Beschreibung spottet denn auch ganz ohne
Wolf geht es den Schäfern nicht
besonders gut Selbstausbeutung ist an
der Tagesordnung Stundenlöhne von sechs
Euro sind keine Ausnahme und das bei
einem Arbeitsalltag von zwölf Stunden
und länger ohne Wochenende und ohne
geregelten Urlaub wir fordern eine
soziale Absicherung die dem Engagement
auch dieser Berufsgruppe gerecht wird
die Regierung muss endlich in der
weidetierhaltung für soziale und
ökologische Gerechtigkeit sorgen und das
sage ich klar mit Blick auf dem die
Fehlstellen im aktuellen
Haushaltsentwurf denn nämlich dann
nämlich wird der Wolf auch dort als eine
Tatsache für viele erträgliche wenn der
soziale Ausgleich erfolgt und das sollte
doch unser Ziel sein
sagt Ina lattendorf die Population der
Wölfe wächst seit Jahren momentan soll
es 157
Wolfsrudel geben allerdings gehören zu
so einem Rudel immer fünf bis zehn Tiere
das ist dann gar nicht so einfach die
Gesamtzahl anzugeben Ulrike Harzer
spricht jetzt für die FDP-Fraktion liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Thema das uns
vorliegenden Antrages der cdu/csu ist
insbesondere die Problematik der
zunehmenden Wolfspopulation in
Deutschland diese geschiedenen Zahlen
sind aus artenschutzrechtlichen Sicht
aufgrund der gewünschten wieder ansieht
Ansiedlung ein voller Erfolg
die wachsende Menge an Wölfen
insbesondere in einigen der wolfsreichen
Regionen Deutschlands entwickelt sich
jedoch inzwischen zu einer zunehmenden
Herausforderung für den Menschen und
hierbei besonders für die Weite
Tierhaltung
trotz umfangreicher Präventionsmaßnahmen
wie Zäune herzschutzhunde steigen die
Probleme für die Weite Tierhalter
wolfsrisse von Weidetieren wie Schafen
Rindern Pferden neben signifikant zu die
Union bemängelt nun in ihrem Antrag wie
so oft in letzter Zeit Zustände und
gesetzliche Regelungen zu deren Klärung
und Umsetzung sich selbst ausreichend
Zeit hatten und deren unzureichende
Erfüllung sie selbst zu verantworten
haben
das betrifft sowohl das Wolfsmonitoring
zur Beobachtung der Bestandsentwicklung
des Wolfes als auch das Wolfsmanagement
selbst
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
dennoch sind in dem Antrag einige
wichtige Punkte enthalten auch wir
wollen das Zusammenleben von weitet
Tieren Mensch und Wolf gut und mit
möglichst wenigen Konflikten gestalten
gerade der angestrebte Anstieg von Weite
Tierhaltung in der Natur statt im Stall
und der Städte Zuwachs des
wolfsbestandes erhöhen die Spannung und
die Konflikte
dem Schutz von Wölfen weite Tieren und
den menschlichen Bedürfnissen muss aus
diesem Grunde gleichermaßen Rechnung
getragen werden und zur Wahrheit gehört
eben auch bessere Kriterien für die
Möglichkeit zur Entnahme von Wölfen zu
schaffen
bereits im Koalitionsvertrag der letzten
Wahlperiode hatten sie sich liebe
Kollegen von der Union ähnliche Ziele
selbst schon vorgenommen und haben in
vier Jahren keine ausreichende Lösung
herbeigeführt
die 2020 erfolgte Änderungen war nicht
weitreichend genug sie haben solchen
regionales Bestandsmanagement zwar
mehrfach diskutiert in ihre Fraktion wie
zum Beispiel in ihre Pressemitteilung
von 219 ersichtlich ist aber diese nicht
eingeführt hätten sie dies getan und
ihre Vorgaben tatsächlich umgesetzt
während die Kleinen Anfragen von ihnen
zu Beginn der neuen Legislatur zu diesem
Thema überflüssig gewesen
entweder
waren sie nicht willens genug oder der
Weg zur Problemlösung ist dann doch
komplexer und langwieriger in beiden
Fällen ist ihre Kritik an der Ampel für
ihre eigenen Versäumnisse unangemessen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren die Ampeln
hat sich im Koalitionsvertrag
vorgenommen die Monitoring Standards zu
überarbeiten um den Wolfsbestand in
Deutschland
realitätstreugetreu abbilden zu können
darüber hinaus werden wir den Ländern
ein regionaldifferenziertes
Bestandsmanagement ermöglichen wichtig
ist hier jedoch wohl überlegt diese
Maßnahmen umzusetzen denn sie müssen im
Einklang mit den schwierigen
Rahmenbedingungen des europäischen
Rechts stehen um für alle Beteiligten
rechtssichere Verhältnisse zu schaffen
Schnellschüsse helfen uns hier nicht
weiter
als Ampel werden wir uns jedoch dieses
Thema es annehmen und deshalb ihren
Antrag für die weitere Arbeit in den
Ausschuss vorweisen und freuen uns auf
Ihre Mitarbeiter vielen Dank
so jetzt gab es schon eine ganze Menge
Zwischenrufe von dem Herrn Otto jetzt
darf er richtig mal hier vom Mikrofon
sprechen für die cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin vielen
Dank für die Begrüßung ich meine es sehr
ernst und die Lage in unserer Region ist
tot ernst und wird hier in Teilen der
Lage nicht angemessen und der Hocker was
haben Sie damals für den Wahlkampf
gemacht ich wünsche Ihnen nur dass sie
diesen Elan den sie damals vor der Wahl
hatten auch gegenüber ihrem
Koalitionspartner zum Ausdruck bringen
denn ich will ihnen eins sagen
versetzen Sie sich mal bitte in die Lage
der Schafhalter vor Ort in 13 Angriffen
79 tote Tiere und noch viele die bei
lebendigen Leibe dort liegen und
vegetieren und der Ebner ich hätte mir
bei ihrer Rede einmal Konstrukt Herr
Ebner
ich hätte mir bei ihrer
dann spreche ich halt nicht zu ihnen
sondern zum Haus ich hätte mir von Herrn
Ebner mal konstruktive Vorschläge
vorgestellt und was ich überhaupt nicht
verstehe dass die zuständigen Minister
für Landwirtschaft und für Umwelt heute
nicht da sind was ist denn das für ein
Umgehen mit der Situation vor Ort
dieses Bild was ich ihnen schildere ist
tagtäglich bei mir im Wahlkreis bei uns
in der Lüneburger Heide in dem
wolfsverdichteten Gebiet der Welt
tagtäglich zu sehen hier werden die
letzten beide Tiere verschwinden das
letzte Rotwild kommt unter Druck aber
vor allem die scharfheiter werden
aufgeben und da ist es eben nicht mit
Erstattungen getan sondern der Stress
der tägliche die viele Arbeit die Sorgen
die Fürsorge um die Tiere die scharfheit
der leben von und mit den Tieren sie
werden ihn nicht gerecht wir müssen hier
den Zustand ändern meine Damen und
Herren und da haben sie die Regierung
Tiere im Wald Tiere auf der Heide
Schäfer auf der Heide alles ist dann weg
wenn wir so weitermachen jetzt muss
gehandelt werden es ist genug evaluiert
worden die Zahlen sind da der günstige
Erhaltungszustand ist längst gegeben und
das müssen sie nach Brüssel melden damit
die Tiere in den anderen fünf kommen und
man hier in Berlin Möglichkeiten hat die
Gesetze anzupassen meine Damen und
Herren
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage aus vom
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
[Musik]
Herr
geschätzter Kollege Otte
sie sprachen gerade in ihrer Rede davon
das Rotwild sei durch den Wolf bereits
in Bedrängnis geraten
wie Sie vielleicht wissen sind unsere
anstrengenden groß in Zeiten des
Klimawandels die Natur für Jungen die
nächste Wald Generation irgendwie hoch
zu bekommen und die hohen wilddichten in
Deutschland tragen ihren Teil dazu bei
dass dieser Erfolg diese harte Arbeit
vieler försterinnen und Förster nur
schwer gelingt und deswegen möchte ich
ich sie fragen ob sie von diesem Problem
der hohen wilddichten wissen und ob sie
davon wissen dass der Wolf hier
natürlich auch ein Beitrag wieder
leisten könnte um in ein natürliches
Gleichgewicht zu kommen dass heute so
nicht vorhanden ist und dass heute
erfolgreichen Waldumbau fit für die
Zukunft nur sehr schwer möglich macht
sehr geschätzter Kollege da fragen Sie
genau den richtigen ich habe viele
Pflanzen selbst gesetzt im Wald ich bin
selbst Jäger ich komme aus der
Lüneburger Heide und ich lade sie ganz
ganz herzlich mal ein nicht nur unsere
Truppenübungsplätze zu besuchen sondern
auch die Gebiete wo die Förster sind
aber wo auch die privaten Waldbauer sind
das Rotwild kommt dermaßen unter Druck
und wird auch bei lebendigem Leibe
aufgefressen und sie haben auch
Verantwortung für Flora und Fauna meine
Damen und Herren und deswegen sage ich
erst wenn das letzte weidetier
verschwunden ist dann brauchen Sie
keinen günstigen haltungszustand mehr zu
melden jetzt haben sie die Verantwortung
meine Damen und Herren
wir haben eine völlige überkonzentration
wir haben von Wölfen und das
Rudelverhalten des Rotwildes ist so dass
sie sich zusammenführen wie Wagenburgen
und ich lade auch sie einzukommen öffnen
sie endlich mal die Augen haben sie mal
Verständnis für die schaffhalterfamilien
wenn die bei lebendigen Leibe sehen wie
ihre Tiere zugrunde gehen meine Damen
und Herren es liegt daran dass wir eine
überkonzentration haben der günstige
Erhaltungszustand ist längst gegeben das
muss nach Brüssel gemeldet werden damit
wir hier in Deutschland Maßnahmen
durchführen können und ich lade die
Umweltministerin der Staatssekretär sehr
herzlich ein beizukommen mit den
scharfheitern mal zu sprechen und nicht
hier uns Populismus vorzuwerfen keiner
ihrer Rednerinnen und Redner hat mal
gesagt was sie machen würden wenn sie
scharfalter werden sie haben nur uns
Populismus vorgeworfen wir setzen uns
ein für die Menschen für die Tiere und
wir fordern sie auf machen sie endlich
von ihrer Verantwortung gebraucht melden
sie endlich die Zahlen da sind nach
Brüssel der günstige Erhaltungszustand
Herr Ebner der ist längst erreicht beim
Wolf es muss jetzt gehandelt werden wir
bitten Sie herzlich darum
ich möchte nur bemerken zwischen Fragen
lasse ich natürlich in der Regel schon
zu aber ich unterbreche auch ungern dann
im Fluss deswegen also wenn die Redner
mir ab und zu eine Chance geben würden
dann auch vielleicht dazu wenn sie es
gar nicht wollen ist es natürlich auch
was anderes ja das hier war eine
Erklärung weil Ralf lenkert aus der
Linksfraktion sich gemeldet hatte aber
eben nicht zum Zuge kam mit einer
Zwischenfrage sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sehr geehrter Herr
Staatssekretär und sehr geehrte Frau
Staatssekretärin sie sind natürlich hier
weil sie dieses Thema auch wichtig
finden
ich möchte einmal was sagen tut mir ein
Auto das war viel Meinung wenig Ahnung
gut ich fand also schon sehr interessant
dass sie ihren den Antrag schon einmal
noch umgeändert haben den Titel
ursprünglich war es weitestyhaltung
durch nachhaltiges
wolfsbestandsmanagement zu ermöglichen
da konnte ich so ein bisschen
nachvollziehen was sie wollen mit dem
jetzigen Titel wollen Sie den Wolf
abschießen das Problem ist einfach
dadurch nicht gelöst wenn sie das nur
damit machen wollen und keinen
Herdenschutz machen dann müssen sie alle
schwölfe abschießen und das schaffen sie
gar nicht mehr
außerdem gibt es eine Reihe von
Einrichtungen die sich intensiv mit
Wolfsmonitoring und Management
beschäftigen es gibt die Dokumentation
und Beratungsstelle des Bundes in
Görlitz und des Bundeszentrum weidet
hier und Wolf der Bundesanstalt für
Ernährung in Eberswalde unser Ziel auf
Bundesebene sollte sein die wirklich die
dauerhaft erforderliche und personell
gut auszustatten damit sie ihre
Erfüllung ihrer Aufgaben wirklich
nachkommen können es gibt auch viele
regionale Institutionen nicht zuletzt
ist wolfskompetenzzentrum meines
Heimatlandes Sachsen-Anhalt denn die
Rückkehr der Wolke erfordert einfach
auch eine präventive Anpassung der
weidetierhaltung
hier ist die Initiative der Tierhalter
unverzichtbar um durch die Wölfe
verursachte Schäden zu vermeiden bzw zu
minimieren Wölfe sind sehr lernfähig und
bei mangelhaftem oder
fehlenden Präventionsmaßnahmen können
wiederholt Übergriffe eine Herde
wirklich gefährden Vorbeugung ist die
beste schadensfortwortverhütung
beide Tiere sind essentiell für den
Erhalt der Kulturlandschaft wir nehmen
daher die berechtigten Sorgen der
weidetierhalter sehr ernst und natürlich
muss ihnen eine wirtschaftliche Zukunft
ermöglicht werden und das kann nur mit
effektiven Herdenschutz funktionieren
das beginnt mit einer individuellen
Beratung denn man kann das Geld nur
sinnvoll verwenden wenn man weiß wie man
es anstellt und hier ist im Einzelfall
die Maßnahmen müssen genau abgestimmt
werden insbesondere der technische
Herdenschutz ist zu nennen es können
feste oder mobile Zäune sein in
Kombination mit elektrischen Weidezaun
Geräten
die Anschaffung wird finanziell
unterstützt und die Einhaltung von den
mindeststands dazu und Beschaffenheit
ist in den ist eine Voraussetzung für
Entschädigungszahlungen der richtige
Zaun mit der notwendigen Spannung
gewährleistet nach Aussage von Experten
ungefähr 80 Prozent der gesamten
Schutzwirkung durch geeignete
Herdenschutzhunde können Sie das eben
noch mal um 15 Prozent erhöhen ein
Restrisiko ist sicherlich nicht
auszuschließen aber ich habe lange
Erfahrungen in Sachsen-Anhalt und bin
wirklich ein 20 Zaun mit vernünftiger
Spannung war haben in diesen zwei Jahren
keine Verluste ein Weidetieren waren
beklagen
so wir haben also das in der IG
Herdenschutz plus Hund mit wirklich
Leuten das ist ein Schäfermeister der
ist in Sachsen-Anhalt organisiert und er
sagt er hat keinen weidetierhalter den
er beraten hat und der seinen ganzen
Beratungen folgt bisher mit Problemen in
seiner weidetierhaltung festgestellt ich
würde Sie einladen nach Sachsen-Anhalt
kommen sie wir können das zusammen uns
mal anschauen
schauen wir uns die Ergebnisse der
herrenschussmaßnahmen in Sachsen-Anhalt
an während im Monitoring Jahr 1920 erst
385 Nutztiere bei 95 wolfsübergriffen
erwischt hat wann es 2021 nur noch 233
Tiere bei 62 Übergriffen und das bei
einer steigenden rudelzahl so sieht
erfolgreiches Wolfsmanagement aus
Frau Kollegin erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage aus der afd-fraktion
[Musik]
Herdenschutz und die Umsetzung der
artenschutzrechtlichen Regelungen sind
vor allem Ländersache der Bund
unterstützt die Länder dabei tragbare
und sachgerechte Lösungen für
präventiven Herdenschutz zu finanzieren
das erklärte Ziel im Koalitionsvertrag
ist es den Erfahrungsaustausch zu
bündeln daher arbeiten wir gerade an der
Einrichtung eines Dialogs weitet
Tierhaltung und Wolf die sich mit diesen
Fragen befassen
befassten Organisationen und Verbände
werden daran teilnehmen ohne die
Zuständigkeit für die rüstbegutachtung
von Landesbehörden direkt wahrgenommen
werden sollte wie sie es in ihrem Antrag
formulieren würden wir auch dort beraten
in Gebirgslagen und ein Deichen ist der
Herdenschutz eine besondere
Herausforderung es liegt daran dass es
sich oft um unwegsames und
unübersichtliches Gelände handelt oder
aber Vorgaben des Hochwasserschutzes zu
beachten sind was wir nicht machen
können ist die Einrichtung wolfsfreier
Zonen wie sie es in ihrem Antrag
formulieren das haben wir nämlich
festgestellt dass es eu-rechtswidrig
wäre und wie der EuGH in seinem Urteil
vom 10 Oktober 2019 ist auch schon mal
bestätigt hat der Herr Auerhammer hat
eine Rückfrage
also okay es gibt sind noch fünf
Sekunden
aber bitteschön
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin und Frau Dr
Kirsten dass sie die zügenfrage zulassen
sie haben uns jetzt sehr viel erzählt
von den zaunmaßnahmen von den Zeugungen
abgesehen davon dass diese Zone in der
Auslegung dann verdammt schwer sind dass
unsere Schäfer hier sehr viel zu
schleppen im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
haben möchte ich Sie fragen wie stellen
Sie sich vor wie man diese Zäune am
hochfellen am hochriss in den Bergen
aufstellen soll oder an den Teichen wie
stellen Sie sich vor dass man hier einen
wolfssicheren Zaun über die Berge weiß
nicht ob sie den jubiläumsgrad kennen ob
sie diese Bergregionen kennen wie
stellen Sie sich vor dass man hier
wolfssichere Zäune aufstellen kann und
da ich überweist dass sie gleich mit den
Argumenten Herdenschutzhunde kommen wir
haben hier wunderbare Wandergebiete hier
ist der Tourismus auch eine
Einkommenssituation eine
Einkommensquelle für die ganzen Täler
wie wollen Sie sicherstellen dass diese
Herdenschutz die Touristen auch wenn sie
aus Sachsen-Anhalt kommen nicht
angreifen dankeschön
kann sich 21 gemeinsam mit uns
einschließungsantrag geschlossen haben
die Forschung zu effektiven Herdenschutz
in diesen besonderen Gebieten zu
unterstützen und aktuell läuft genau
dieses forschungsforschungsprojekt an
der Hochschule für Wirtschaft und Umwelt
Nürtingen Geislingen und wir sind sicher
gut beraten uns die Ergebnisse dieser
wissenschaftlichen Untersuchung
anzuschauen um danach zu entscheiden wie
wir damit weiter vorgehen
außerdem möchte ich gerne betonen dass
das Land Niedersachsen aus Landesmitteln
Forschung zu besserem herrenschutz auch
an Deichen fördert dort werden
Umweltschutz und Landwirtschaft eben
immer schon zu zusammen gedacht und mein
Dank geht daher an den Minister Olaf
Lies
wenn es trotz Herdenschutz zu nutzen
durch Wölfe kommt werden diese
selbstverständlich entschädigt und ich
bin schon noch einmal Prävention durch
Herdenschutz ist der beste und
eigentlich der einzige Weg vielen Dank
und das Wort geht noch mal an die
cdu/csu-fraktionen Alexander Radwan
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich spreche jetzt hier nicht
weil ich den zuständigen Ausschüssen bin
sondern weil ich wie der Kollege Otte
als lokale Abgeordneter mit dem Thema
konfrontiert bin aber jetzt weniger im
Norden sondern im Süden dort wo die
Almen zu Hause sind und dort ist schon
seit sehr sehr langer Zeit des Wolf ein
großes Thema
und dort haben die Bauern schlicht und
ergreifendes Gefühl dass Teile der
deutschen Politik der Wolf wichtiger ist
als ihre Hilfe als die Almen als der
halt Erhalt der kleinen Landwirtschaft
meine Damen und Herren
und das betrifft uns in Bayern bei den
Almen bei den Alpen aber auch in Tirol
und die Meldung die ich die Tage
bekommen habe ist aus Tirol 300 Tiere
gerissen über 1500 Tiere frühzeitig
abgetrieben weil es die Bauern satt
haben und ihre Tiere nicht mehr sicher
sind tun sie diese runter für meine
Damen und Herren
unsere Bauern gerade die einbauern
Arbeiten mit sehr viel Idealismus mit
sehr viel Leidenschaft auf ihren Almen
setzen sich dort eines ist sehr
arbeitsintensiv und viele profitieren
davon Ausflügler wandra Mountainbiker
ist möchte ich das zu Ende führen
einfach mal aber eh nur drei Minuten
wollen das zu Ende führen besten Dank
und viele profitieren davon
und dann ist es umso erstaunlicher wenn
bestimmt die Ziele die immer hoch
gehalten werden wie Tierschutz wie
Anbindehaltung soll verhindert werden
und so weiter konterkariert werden weil
ein natürlicheres Leben wie auf der Alm
gibt es für die Tiere nicht was ist
Ihnen da wichtiger wollen Sie dass die
Stück für Stück aufhören und dieses
entsprechend nach dem was bleibt
eigentlich mit der Art und Vielfalt wenn
in kürzester Zeit die Almen wieder
versteppen und es zurückgeht meine Damen
und Herren da sind sie selber nicht
konsistent in ihrer Argumente ihnen ist
der Wolf wichtiger als all die anderen
Argumente diese regelmäßig anführen und
der Höhepunkt war vor einem Jahr da
haben die Bauern sich die Mühe gemacht
mal so einen Zaun hinzustellen und da
war dann der Vertreter des BUND
Naturschutzes und der hat bei seinem
Grundwort gesagt ich bin dafür dass es
Bauern einbauern und Wolf eine
Koexistenz gibt wenn dieses aber nicht
möglich ist da müssen die allen Bauern
die seit Jahr müssen ihre Almen haben
eben ihren Betrieb einstellen das sagt
dieser Mann diesen Menschen ins Gesicht
die alles daran setzen unsere
Kulturlandschaft entsprechend zu
erhalten meine Dame und Herren in
manchen Regionen ist eine Koexistenz
nicht möglich da darf man nicht nur
träumen sondern da muss man die Realität
ins Gesicht schauen man muss diese
Menschen in ihren Sorgen ernst nehmen
und schauen dass die Almwirtschaft dort
vorangeht und nicht nur in Sonntagsreden
oder bei allen Begehungen entsprechend
das große Lied singen und am Schluss die
Menschen allein lassen besten Dank meine
Damen und Herren
fragt sie uns über die Reifen dann
Applaus für Alexander Radwan hier haben
auch durchaus einige
afd-abgeordnete applaudiert und
natürlich seine eigene Fraktion die
Union jetzt gibt es eine
kurzintervektion von Ralf lenkert aus
der Linksfraktion
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Kollege radwahn
sind ihnen die Zahlen bekannt dass es im
Jahre 2005 in Deutschland
2,64 Millionen Schafe gab im Jahre 2013
also fast noch keine Wolfsbestände gab
war die Zahl auf 1,5 Millionen Schafe
gesunken um diese Zahl pegelt sie sich
bis heute ein die Ursache ist die
unzureichende Finanzierung der
weidetierhaltung und meine Kollegin
ehemal Kollegen Kirstin Tackmann hat sie
jedes Jahr darauf hingewiesen dass wir
dringend eine weidetierprämie brauchen
um eben die weidetierhalter die
Schäferin und Schäfer und auch ihre
einbauern zu unterstützen damit sie eben
die Kulturlandschaft behalten können sie
haben dies jedes Mal verhindert
ich möchte Sie darauf hinweisen
dass wir auch dieses Jahr wieder 50
Millionen Euro extra fordern für eine
weidet hier Prämie für die weiter
Heilung damit eben die Weite Tierhalter
die Schäferin und Schäfer mit die eine
Chance haben zu überleben was haben sie
gefordert sie fordern Wolf abschießen
das ist alles was sie kennen das ist
doch billig und ein nächster Punkt
lang meine Kollegin Kirsten taktmann hat
das jedes Mal gefordert endlich mehr
weideschutzmaßnahmen zu finanzieren
beide Schutzhunde zu finanzieren weil
ein herdenschutzzentrum richtig
aufzubauen sie haben dies verhindert und
jetzt einfach die Wölfe abschießen
wollen ist der falsche und selbst wenn
jeder Wolf getötet werden wird Liebe
Schäferin und Schäfer wird ihre Existenz
trotzdem nicht besser weil sie eben die
weidetierhaltung nicht gut finanziert
bekommen weil sie nicht genügend Geld
verdienen können ohne eine Weile
tierprämie werden Sie nicht überleben
können ob mit Wolf oder ohne Wolf und
deswegen fordern wir eine Weile für
Prämie
wollen sie erwidern ja bitteschön
ich gefragt ob ich die Zahlen kenne ich
kann Ihnen sagen was bei mir in diesem
Sommer in den Alpen passiert ist und was
mir die bauen erzählt haben das kann ich
Ihnen erzählen und da können sie gerne
mal rauskommen und sich die bauen
entsprechend anhören wenn bei Ihnen und
bei mir geht es nicht primär am Schafe
sondern auch um die Kuhhaltung und die
Tiere dort wenn die dann über die Klippe
abstürzen können Sie gerne vorbeikommen
und sich das entsprechend anschauen und
ich halte es und das abschließend für
einen blanken Zynismus die Bauern fragen
mich nicht nach Geld oder irgendwelche
entsprechenden Zahlungen dafür sie
wollen in Ruhe sicher für ihre Tiere
sorgen und nicht zu sehen wie sie
verenden müssen das ist purer Zionismus
was sie hier sagen dass die dazu schauen
müssen
soweit hier eine kurze Intervention und
dann die wiederung und damit kommen wir
zur letzten Rednerin in dieser Debatte
Zoe Maja spricht jetzt für Bündnis 90
die Grünen im Bundestag
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen es
ist ja schon ein bisschen absurd die
Menschheit die weiß wie man zum Mond
fliegt aber beim Punkt Weide Tierschutz
oder weidet hier Haltung der fällt der
Union wirklich gar nichts anderes ein
außer abschießen und das ist wirklich
sehr sehr traurig bei so einer Debatte
sie beide Tierhaltung ist ein großer
Fortschritt für den Tierschutz weil
natürlich ist die weidetierhaltung
besser als alles was die
stealthierhaltung zu bieten hat und die
weidetierhaltung hat noch andere
positive Aspekte auf unsere Umwelt zum
Beispiel beim Landschaftsschutz oder
beim Humusaufbau und deswegen müssen wir
die beide Tierhaltung politisch
natürlich unterstützen
wir haben eindeutig auch Probleme mit
wolfsrissen und wir erkennen das an und
genau deswegen beschäftigen wir uns auch
damit ernsthafte Maßnahmen zu finden und
fordern nicht einfach wildpopulistisch
den Wolf abschießen wir wissen dass es
das Problem nicht lösen wird wir haben
schon einige Punkte heute zum Thema
Herdenschutz angesprochen und auch meine
Kollegin Franziska Kersten hat ja
bereits darauf hingewiesen wir haben
eine tolle Dokumentation darüber was
hilft und was können wir eigentlich tun
beim Herdenschutz und wir sehen auch in
über 80 Prozent der Fällen wo es
wolfsschlüsse gab für Schafen und Ziegen
da gab es keinen hinreichenden
Herdenschutz oder sogar gar keinen
Herdenschutz und da müssen wir ansetzen
da müssen wir auch von unseren Nachbarn
Ländern lernen die ja schon länger auch
den Wolf beheimaten
Frau Kollegin erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage
tatsächlicher dazu schon alles gesagt
mir ist es wichtig noch mal darauf
hinzuweisen wir haben in den Ländern ja
flächendeckend auch schon
Förderprogramme fast alle Bundesländer
bieten das an und auch der Bund
unterstützt ja mit Fördermitteln über
die gab und über die GAG also es
passiert viel und wir sind natürlich
bereit fortwährend auch unser
Instrumentarium weiterzuentwickeln und
da könnten sie sich auch mal konstruktiv
einbringen das glaube ich wollen sie
aber gar nicht an der Stelle und alle
die heute den Abschuss des Wolfes
fordern die sollen uns doch bitte einmal
nachweisen die sollen uns einmal
nachweisen dass das Abschießen wirklich
eine wirksame und vor allen Dingen eine
gerechtfertigtere Maßnahme für den
Tierschutz und für den Artenschutz ist
als die anderen Maßnahmen die wir haben
das tun sie nicht und ich bin mir sicher
sie können es auch nicht
zum Abschluss der Debatte muss man
natürlich sagen und gerade weil die
cdu/csu heute so viel über Tierschutz
gesprochen hat es ist natürlich die
traurige Ironie heute dass wenn der Wolf
am Ende die Weidetiere nicht tötet der
Mensch tut es ganz sicher und deswegen
ist der beste Tierschutz natürlich gar
nicht zu töten vielen Dank
[Applaus]
für eine Kurzintervention erhält die
Kollegin Damerow das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Kollegin sie haben
sehr viel gesprochen von weidetierschutz
von zaunschutz und so weiter nun mein
Wahlkreis ist das nördliche Nord ist das
Nordfriesland ist Nordfriesland und es
nördliche Dithmarschen hinter den
Deichen wie Sie vielleicht wissen ist
beide können Sie ein bisschen näher ans
bis beide
ist Zaunbau auf den Deichen nicht zu
verwirklichen auf der anderen Seite ist
scharfhaltung auf unseren Deichen
unverzichtbar um die den Deichbau
überhaupt erst nur sicher zu machen
jetzt frage ich sie wie soll denn in
einer Region wieder meinen ein weiter
ein ein beide Tierschutz indem man eben
nicht Zäunen kann funktionieren übrigens
das ähnliche Problem wie auf den Almen
da haben sie keine Antworten drauf
dieses Thema diskutieren wir mit
diskutieren wir wirklich schon sehr
lange und das treibt die Schafhalter in
meiner Region um da ist nämlich Ende mit
wir ziehen Zäune geht nicht und
Hundehaltung Hütehunde geht ebenfalls
nicht was schlagen Sie diesen Menschen
vor sind sie wenigstens bereit sich
darüber Gedanken zu machen dass wir in
Deutschland auch Regionen brauchen in
denen es den Wolf nicht gibt
Frau Kollegin Meier und sie wieder
ja sie sprechen natürlich an wir hätten
uns nicht mit Maßnahmen befasst ich
finde es einfach sehr sehr traurig wie
gesagt dass die Union nichts anderes zu
bieten hat außer abschießen da sind wir
uns ja alle einig wie sie auch schon
artenschutzrechtlich heute einmal
ausführlich begründet bekommen haben das
geht auch nicht wir haben einige
Möglichkeiten für den Herdenschutz wie
gesagt Frau Dr Kersten hat das schon
einiges aufgezählt ich möchte nicht die
Redundanz in die Debatte reinbringen
immer wieder die gleichen Argumente zu
wiederholen aber sie sind sehr herzlich
eingeladen sich konstruktiv bei uns an
dieser Debatte zu beteiligen wenn der
einzige Vorschlag immer wieder ist
abschießen dann ist das leider nicht
konstruktiv vielen Dank
ich schließe die Aussprache die Fraktion
der cdu/csu hat beantragt über Ihren
Antrag auf Drucksache 36,90 abzustimmen
die Fraktion SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP wünschen Überweisung und zwar
federführend an den Ausschuss für Umwelt
Naturschutz nukleare Sicherheit und
Verbraucherschutz und mit beratend an
den Ausschuss für Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft wir stimmen nach
ständiger Übung zunächst mal über die
Ausschussüberweisung ab und ich frage
deshalb wer stimmt für die beantragte
Überweisung
das ist die SPD Bündnis 90 die Gründung
die FDP wer stimmt dagegen das ist die
linke cdu/cs und die afd-enthaltung sehe
ich keine dann ist die Überweisung so
beschlossen damit stimmen wir heute über
den Antrag auf Drucksache 36,90 nicht in
der Sache ab